[Música]
es una pregunta con la que me ha topado
muchas veces y honestamente la respuesta
es muy triste porque porque como bien
saben la exploración espacial hoy en día
se ha convertido en el huevo de oro de
la innovación tecnológica ha avanzado y
ha crecido exponencialmente de una forma
que jamás nos hubiéramos imaginado pero
aún así la sociedad le da la espalda e
ignora muchas cosas que la exploración
espacial nos puede ofrecer aportes como
la comunicación global
avances en la electrónica mecánica
metodología tecnología que han ayudado a
prevenir catástrofes naturales e incluso
ha movido la medicina y muchos otros
aspectos en nuestra vida diaria que
ignoramos casi por completo
lo peor de todo es que eso no es algo
que sucede únicamente con la exploración
espacial esto pasa en casi los campos de
la ciencia por lo que hoy en día
nosotros o gran parte de nosotros
contamos con tecnología cada vez más
avanzada y capaz de adaptarse a nuestras
necesidades
por lo mismo
no hay muchas personas o las suficientes
que se dediquen a estos vastos temas de
ciencia lo cual a su vez es provocado
porque muchas personas y jóvenes en
general tienen miedo de desarrollarse en
estos temas
pero hablar alrededor del mundo hay
muchísimos jóvenes como yo que soñamos a
lo grande y buscamos tener una carrera
que nos lleve a trabajar en una empresa
tan grande e importante como la nasa y
spaces pro miro a mi alrededor a mis
compañeros y amigos en la gran mayoría
tienen la idea de que su futuro o su
sueño es aquel que se enfoca en ser
abogados doctores
políticos entre muchos otros y que son
carreras demasiado importantes y que el
mundo necesita totalmente
pero porque no es normal que un joven yo
porque no es normal que veamos posible
para un joven llegar a desarrollarse en
un campo de trabajo así y que llegue a
ser unas notas
la verdad no estaría mal algo de
variedad y espacio para abrirnos a la
ciencia y la tecnología y que de una vez
no es imposible o aparentemente
imposible para un joven llegar a
trabajar en nuestros campos de trabajo
desde pequeño yo he tenido claro en
sueños y mis objetivos y he buscado
mucha información al respecto de hecho
el año pasado me certifique en un curso
de ahorro de energía uno de teoría
cuántica y otro de astronomía
además de que pienso realizar muchos más
relacionados con la mecánica la
ingeniería aeroespacial las matemáticas
la física etcétera
además de los cursos he desarrollado
proyectos que me buscan bueno que me
impulsan a la búsqueda de conocimientos
sobre el universo que nos rodea por
ejemplo hace tiempo que realicé toda una
investigación histórica sobre el
alunizaje del apolo 11 en 1969 en la
cual muestro evidencia de que en efecto
el hombre lleva a la luna
otro ejemplo es un proyecto que de hecho
acabo de realizar hace poco en el cual
me adentré en el proceso que siguieron
los astrónomos para calcular la
distancia entre la tierra y la luna si
no lo saben eso es gracias al paralaje
es decir
el ángulo que se forma entre un objetivo
y dos puntos de observación
en resumidas cuentas lo que hice fue
seleccionar la fecha del 21 de enero del
2019 esto debido a que mi cumpleaños es
el 21 de enero y fuese 1 del 2019 hubo
un eclipse lunar con las características
perfectas para su observación
después selecciona los puntos de
observación de madrid y montevideo esto
debido a que la luna debe de encontrarse
en posiciones diferentes o direcciones
opuestas en el cielo después con la
aplicación sky safari tomé algunas
capturas de pantalla de la luna siendo
vista de los desde los diferentes puntos
de observación para después comparar y
medir la distancia de diferencia entre
las lunas respecto a las estrellas de
fondo
después con ayuda de las matemáticas y
algunos datos ya predeterminados poder
conocer el ángulo de paralaje que es el
que los comentaba hace rato y después
con ello de la trigonometría puede
calcular la distancia entre la tierra y
la luna
al final me dio una instancia muy
similar a la que encontré en internet y
puede realizar un modelo escala de cómo
se vería en la tierra y la luna
separadas por estas grandes distancias
los invito a merlo tantito
de seguro muchos de ustedes pensarían
que estarían mucho más cerca
un tanto así
esto es debido a que la educación que
recibimos así nos lo enseñó
de ahí me afirmación que la sociedad
ignora demasiadas cosas sobre el mundo
en el que vivimos
perdón
la verdad estoy muy nervioso
sí
pero es lo que quiere hacer la verdad y
yo hay que hacer esto me alcanzará bueno
me va a ayudar a alcanzar mis objetivos
entonces
lo que quiero llegar es qué
o sea eso yo lo hago por mi propia
voluntad y ves porque sé que es algo que
me va a ayudar a alcanzar mis objetivos
explicó desde pequeño he tenido claros
mis objetivos y mis sueños
hola de nuevo perdón por lo que pasó
hace rato la verdad debo admitir que fue
un fail total y la verdad no me
arrepiento ni me siento avergonzado
les digo por qué por qué miro al pasado
y las personas que fueron antes de mí y
que de verdad admiro
miro sus fracasos y sus éxitos personas
como el al mosco que como bien saben sus
cohetes explotan a cada rato pero él no
se da por vencido entonces aquí estoy de
nuevo y voy a terminar lo que empecé
[Aplausos]
bueno básicamente me quedé aquí
donde les conté o bueno les mostré esta
imagen que es un modelo de escala de la
luna y la tierra después les mostré esta
otra imagen que básicamente es la imagen
que nos mostraron a todos de pequeños
esto demuestra mi punto de que la
sociedad ignora demasiadas cosas sobre
el mundo en el que vivimos
de hecho si yo mostrara la típica imagen
del sistema solar que de hecho no lo voy
a mostrar pero si la mostrara y la
comparamos con un modelo de escala del
sistema solar notaríamos que los
planetas ni siquiera son visibles de lo
pequeño que son en realidad
claro que todo esto habría sido mucho
más fácil de entender y realizar si
tuviéramos la oportunidad de estudiar y
profundizar sobre estos temas en la
escuela
personalmente estoy demasiado agradecido
por tener la oportunidad de estar en una
escuela en la que mi profesor de
matemáticas me permite investigar sobre
mis propios gustos y usar este
experimento como proyecto
aunque de mencionar a todos aquellos
jóvenes que al igual que yo sueñan con
alcanzar metas similares pero no cuentan
con las mismas oportunidades
todavía aún he de mencionar a todos
aquellos que no tienen ni idea del
potencial que tienen y todo lo que
pueden lograr
de verdad muchísimos jóvenes alrededor
del mundo piensan que no podrían tener
éxito en una de estas carreras miran al
pasado y a todas las personas antes de
ellos que han aportado a este mundo
lleno de tecnología como bill gates
elon musk isaac newton entre muchos
otros y piensan que son casos únicamente
extraordinarios para gente únicamente
dotada lo cual no es verdad
y esas personas realmente merecen todo
su éxito y todo su reconocimiento pero
lo que quiero dar a entender es que cada
uno de nosotros tiene el potencial para
hacer de este mundo un lugar mejor
lo que propongo para acercarnos cada vez
más a todos estos jóvenes es hacer
algunos cambios en la sociedad y el
sistema educativo
empezando por buscar quitarle todo este
miedo a estos jóvenes y además fundar y
apoyar instituciones que busquen ayudar
a todos estos jóvenes todos los jóvenes
que quieren estudiar y que se esfuerzan
pero que no tienen las oportunidades y
recursos económicos
e instituciones como the mighty khan
academy entre muchas otras
aunque no todo depende de las acciones y
decisiones que toman los demás alrededor
tuyo si eres alguien que sueñas
verdaderamente con algo puede que
parezca casi imposible pero no lo es y
si de verdad lo deseas lo vas a lograr
puedes hacer muchas cosas al respecto
como yo que estoy tomando cursos y
proyectos que me impulsan a la búsqueda
del conocimiento que me puede ayudar en
un futuro además de toda la información
que tienes a la palma de tu mano como
dijo en moscú
no necesitas ir a la universidad para
aprender cosas ese conocimiento está
disponible de forma gratuita
aunque este es sólo un ejemplo y no
espero realmente que nadie abandone sus
estudios pero quiero dar a entender que
es hora de que nosotros los alumnos
hagamos algo al respecto y busquemos por
lo que queremos pues nosotros somos el
futuro del mundo y nuestro futuro
nosotros lo creamos tampoco podemos
esperar a que nuestros padres y el
colegio nos digan qué hacer a dónde ir y
dónde buscar pero es cierto que dentro
del plan de estudio debería de haber
tiempo para desarrollar hobbies que nos
ayudarán a crecer y alcanzar nuestros
sueños y objetivos
vivimos en una sociedad en la que
nosotros los ciudadanos tenemos que
hacer algo al respecto aprender a cuidar
de nuestro planeta por ejemplo
y muchas de las formas que podemos
hacerlo es a través de las 100 a través
de la aplicación de la ciencia y la
tecnología
además de generar conciencia claro
estoy seguro que a medida que se le da
más importancia al estudio la ciencia y
la tecnología
es un pequeño paso para un alumno pero
un gran salto para la humanidad
es sólo cuestión de construir el cohete
que nos impulsa a la búsqueda del
conocimiento muchas gracias
no